hi everyone and welcome to the webinar
know your rights intellectual property
considerations for the emerging designer
and freelancer this event is organized
by the design singapore council
in partnership with ella cheung llc and
is supported by the national design
center
this event is also part of the national
design center's next-gen program lineup
for october to november this year
i am felicia from the design singapore
council and i will be your mc for today
today's session will cover key ip
considerations that emerging designers
and freelancers should take note of and
will touch
on important practical aspects like
design registration
ownership copyright issues as well as
licensing
the session will begin with a
presentation by our partner ella chung
llc
followed by a q a segment and will close
with the sharing by the design singapore
council
on the various shared services that are
available for design firms
and last but definitely not least our
attendees today will also get to enjoy a
complimentary one-to-one
preliminary consultation with ella
cheong llc's team of professionals
so more details on this will be shared
at the end of the webinar so do stick
around if you'd like to make use of this
very helpful resource
so without further ado i'm very honored
to introduce our presenting speaker
mr marcus chen marcus is a legal
associate at ella chung llc
a leading specialist intellectual
property law firm in singapore and asia
he assists in a variety of commercial
and contentious work in relation to
iplaw
and handles the trademark portfolios for
both local and international clients
advising them on the ip filing
strategies prosecution management
and also the enforcement of their ip
marcus is familiar with domain name
disputes and also has experience in
legal areas under franchising
distributorship data protection as well
as software licensing
it is now my pleasure to hand over the
time to marcus
marcus over to you please
thank you felicia for the kind
introduction now let me just share my
screen
okay so um i hope everyone can see my
screen over here
now um thank you everyone for tuning in
today
as felicia said my name is marcus i'm
from ella chong llc
and today we'll be sharing some tips um
you know on how
for certain ip considerations for the
emerging designer and freelancer
now let me just give a brief
introduction of our firm
ella chong llc is a boutique ip law firm
based in singapore
and we are well placed to assist our
clients in their ip matters
in jurisdictions such as asean as well
as asia
now we have three officers around the
world
and some of you may know that our
founding partner
ella chong she was actually invited from
hong kong
to to start the budding ip industry
in singapore and back then when asean
did not have a strong ip grounding
so she was quite a renowned ip lawyer
and she was
invited to set up set up shop here and
you know since then we have now expanded
our reach
into more than 100 jurisdictions we have
represented over 10 000 ip owners
for their various matters and
as you can see there are about 30 000 ip
writes being managed
today so now moving on to our
presentation proper
we will first talk about what ip is and
what counts as ip
as most of you might be aware it is a
term with increasing importance and
influence in the world today
not just for businesses but also for
individuals and in particular
individuals working in the creative
industries like yourselves
after going through briefly some of the
major types of ip
we shall narrow in on the regulations
surrounding registered designs
and copyright next we will look at the
relevant rules that may apply
to the emerging designer and freelancer
as well as key ib considerations that
may be
important to you finally i'll be sharing
some recent updates that may apply to
your work
and some key takeaways and practical
tools and tones for everyone
now what is intellectual property
some of you may may know this but not
everyone is actually aware
ip refers to intangible creations of the
mind
such as inventions literary or artistic
works
designs symbols names or even images
used in commerce every one of us
actually experiences
ip when we go about our daily lives
for example a trademark is a sign that
you can use to distinguish your
business's
goods or services from those of others
they can identify the origin of the
source of these goods or services
a patent is a right granted to an owner
of an invention
that prevents others from replicating
that invention
and you may a person who owns a patent
can use it
sell it sell the invention or even to
import or export
overseas a trade secret or confidential
information
is some undisclosed information or a
secret that is
important to a business or company and
is kept out of the public domain
now this can be very very valuable for
businesses for example
you can have a recipe of a very popular
dish or a drink
or even the special processes put in
place by a company
to ensure that its work is efficient
i will delve into the rules on designs
and copyright later
as you will see now first
at this juncture you may be more
familiar with what ip
entails or covers but you may wonder is
it really that important
and if so why is it important
now first we need to understand that ip
or ia
intangible assets is a tremendous growth
engine for the modern economy
traditionally the best performing
companies rely on
tangible assets and these assets will
make up the bulk of the value of the
business or the company
for example companies with a lot of
hardware assets such as those in the
manufacturing or construction lines
not to say that hardware is no longer as
important
but if you fast forward to today you can
see that
84 of the assets of the world's largest
companies
are actually grounded in ip or ia
it also shows you how in a span of about
40 years the focus in growth
comes from a steady ia component
for example a company that is very very
well grounded in ip or ia can hit its
first billion dollars much faster now
than say a company that has more of
hardware assets
now to see how all this may apply to you
let's look at some of the design
regulations in singapore
the industrial design market is
regulated and chiefly protected
by the registered designs act we shall
call it the act
and first what the goals or reasons for
the protection of designs in singapore
now one obvious reason is precisely that
designs contain
eye appeal and the goal of attracting
the customer's attention
this can be said to contain commercial
advantage
if somebody's design of a product is so
successful that it should be protected
from being taken advantage of by others
in the market
great designs provide great value they
attract customers
they build loyalty and they help
increase market share
given the importance of design in
today's world it is important to
understand
how emerging designers and artists are
very crucial in contributing
to a singaporean economy increasingly
reliant on ip
and ia as a key driver of growth and
indeed
singapore's focus on design innovation
as a method to boost the economy
has been planned and discussed way back
in the early 2000s
which i also believe led to the
beginning of design singapore
as it is today now moving on to what it
means
to get a design registered in singapore
very generally
a design must satisfy two criteria
firstly it needs to be a design
it has to be it has to contain a feature
of shape
configuration color pattern or ornament
applied to any article or non-physical
product
by any industrial process the second
component
is that it must be new but do note that
what it means
is it's not new in the sense that it's
new
in relation to iopu but that is not
registered
or published in singapore or anywhere
else in the world
so just a few examples of new designs
can be you know a new board game
or a new electric scooter design or a
new design of a toy
but do note that there are some
exceptions and
um you know these these are probably too
technical or contain
information that is you know topic for
another day
but you just need to know that there are
certain exceptions to
what is considered as a registrable
design
let me just go into an example first one
is the functionality exception
this is in relation to designs that
contain features
of shapes for example which are dictated
solely by their
function next
a design that is a must match exception
this is a design with a feature
or shape that you know is dependent upon
the appearance of another article
for example if i have a design of a car
um
it it it's not likely that the
design of the car door can be registered
because
it is likely that the car door must
match the design of the car
and next the mass fit exception this is
an exception
for certain designs that for obvious
reasons they must fit
um so as such they cannot be something
that is registrable
and another example is an exhaust pipe
of a car
because of the space constraints
and the requirements of of an exhaust
pipe a design for exhaust pipe
is likely not registerable
now as you can see these are some of the
non-exhaustive
requirements that one would need for a
design registration in singapore
as you can already see it's it is
not so straightforward there are there
are quite a lot of information that you
need in order to get design registered
and certainly there are a lot of
questions that are to be asked
for each application on top of that
you need to know that certain kinds of
works are actually
unregistrable as designs or they are
unable to be protected
now what do i mean for example there are
specific types of works
that are not allowed to be registered
these are unregisterable
products unregisterable books of
art for example sculptures or
printed matter primarily of literary or
artistic character
for example calendars certificates
greeting cards labels you know
postcards and even stamps
these for various reasons such as
copyright
they are not able to come under the
umbrella term of a registrable design
and we will explore later how they may
be protected under copyright
now other examples of designs that
cannot be protected
are those that are contrary to public
policy or morality
and other types of artistic works
as we will see later on top of getting
your design registered
you need to know that registered designs
the
protection is territorial so just
because i have my design protected
in singapore it does not mean that i
have a protection everywhere else in the
world
this is especially for young designers
nowadays who need to be aware that
you know with the increase in
connectivity
um in amongst the world today and for
products
all over the world you need to know that
your end goal
your end product or article may be
available overseas
so everyone needs to consider if
they need to have an international
registration for their design
on top of trying to get your design
registered
both locally and internationally
you are also able to track what designs
there are
in both in singapore and other countries
so for example
i could do a search of the singapore
intellectual properties of
singapore offices database
they do have a database of some of the
registered designs in singapore and
their information
and likewise for those around the world
you could check out the
search page at the world intellectual
property organization's website
now as i mentioned earlier there are
some types of works that may not be able
to qualify as registrable designs
why is this so this is because some of
them come
under copyright protection the law of
copyright protects
certain types of artistic works and
as you see what is an artistic work it
is a very broad
category for for many different
industries and types of works
and it largely deals with for example
paintings
sculptures drawings or even photographs
where the world has a certain artistic
quality
and under the laws of copyright um
the the design drawing of a design
itself
for example they may even be considered
artistic words that are protected by
copyright
so it is quite a complicated body of law
because you have um designs that may be
protected
under designs but at the same time you
may have certain drawings or you may
have certain works that are protected
under copyright instead and
the protection safeguards offered under
copyright law
are that it gives you the right to
reproduce the work to publish it
or to communicate it to the public it is
slightly different from having a
registered design right
but you need to know that
copyright is something that is not
registerable under the laws of singapore
it is something that that is arrived at
by default so for example if you are the
the writer
of of of a book you don't actually
register it for copyright in singapore
it is accrued naturally
by virtue of you being the writer so
you know you may be wondering at this at
this stage
your work is not at its final uh
product or article um and you don't know
if the work that you are that you are
working on right now while it has
artistic
um or aesthetic value is it
something that is registerable or is it
something that is unregistrable
in order to consider where your your
work or type of work comes from
you need to look at the interaction
between various types of ip
and today we'll be focusing more on the
interaction between design
and copyright now assuming that a design
is registerable it will not as an
unregistered design
enjoy any protection under both
copyright law
and the registered design law if it's
unregistered
oh sorry if it's registered under the
registered designs act
it will only enjoy protection under the
designs act but not copyright
so therefore your work only enjoys
copyright protection
only if it's unregistable under the
registered designs act
i know it's very complicated so
if your design is registered look at the
act at which you're being registered
the registered design is app if your
design qualifies
but is not registered there is actually
no protection
at all and it is something that is
artistic is not meant for industrial
application
then your starting point should be
copyright
however do note that there are also key
differences between what is a
registrable design
and what may be protected under
copyright for example the visual
expression
of a designer's design may be protected
as an artistic work
under copyright law but also do know
that if you have something that you
you would imagine has copyright
protection if subsequently it's
something that's mass produced
um say 50 articles or sorry more than 50
articles
then it's not something that that
qualifies for copyright protection
so as you can see it it it can be
um troubled waters that that you are
that you are
that you are swimming in especially as
uh you know an emerging designer
and you don't know um what kind of work
your your your design qualifies
under um and especially you know this
kind of things are
industry specific because when it comes
to designs
and works artistic works it really
depends on what kind of work you are
doing
so you often ask yourself where should i
start
first it is important to take a step
back and consider again
why ip is so important and how it can
help you
ip is is able to be used not just
as a swot but also as a shoe as you'll
be able to see
later and here is just an
example of how it how it can really be
quite complicated a
a simple not a simple but a single
product
such as a car can contain various types
of ip
the advertising and promotional content
can be
copyrighted for example but at the same
time
the car design could be a registered
design so
and there are other types of ips as well
that are involved so it is very
complicated
and with that as a background we can
move on to consider
one of the more preliminary issues that
emerging designers should consider
we look at three types of relationships
first
the employer employee relationship where
the design is created by an employee
in the course of his employment the
employer is treated as the owner
of course this would be subject to any
other agreement
between the parties and in the past for
commission works
where the design is created in pursuant
of a commission
the commissioner is treated as the owner
but do note that the law has recently
changed
so that currently the design vest in the
designer by default
and it's only where a
a separate agreement is carved out from
this
and that is where the designer gives up
his rights to his design
and also do note that you know sometimes
the design has more than one
author or more than one artist and
um you could share ownership rights with
your co-owner
or for example if you're licensed out or
you assign out your rights
um you you are not automatically the
only person
who is the sole exclusive owner
and moving on to you know
using your ip as as a as a song you know
as
as as emerging designers you don't just
you do it for your
hobby right you need to make sure that
it's
it's it's your livelihood as well you
need to know how to exploit your ip
and um oftentimes the question you
should consider is whether or not
to do a license or an assignment
now an assignment is in essence a
transfer of ownership
while a license is in essence permission
to do
what um what otherwise would be
infringing
your rights of a design for example so
licensing is something that's
advantageous generally because it allows
the
the the owner to retain control over the
use of your right
so for example if you own the design to
something you still have some
you still have a majority of say over
how to use that particular
design as compared to an assignment
where you could just be assigning your
rights to an organization
and you might not have the same say over
how your design is to be used in future
and of course such licensing gives
permission to others in exchange for
royalties right benefits for yourself
and you know that um
managing your your ip at the start it
doesn't just
help you to to go to that step it's
beyond that
um it builds a good foundation for
financing you know it generates value
through transactions with others and by
having strategic partnerships
subsequently
you use your ip as a tool for
collaboration or even a recognition for
yourself
now we look at some of the things
everyone can undertake you know armed
with the information that we already
have
right first you need to know what your
work involves
what is the legal definition that
applies to your work
for example copyright or is regis or
registrable design more relevant
and on top of understanding your rights
you need to understand
what rights there are of others so that
you don't want to infringe others rights
correct and you need to understand the
the relationships that you have with
other people
you know be it a commissioner or
you know someone that is uh that is
co-writing it for you
and most importantly you need to know um
to conduct an ip audit and
what i mean by ip audit is it is
important to consider
how at every stage of of doing your work
how you can how you can manage your ip
you know
note but what what is to be done so that
you know as you lay the brakes off
of success for yourself um you're you
know what to do at every stage
now um there are some recent updates in
the law i'll just touch on them very
briefly due to um
constraints of time the the registrable
scope of designs has recently been
expanded
to include non-physical products or even
those that have these colors as device
design features
and when you register a design do note
that
now the the ipos examination standards
you know to check whether or not your
design is new or something that's
capable of registration
is stricter but certainly it is more
it provides more certainty
also you know i believe today is the is
the release date of the ps5
everyone knows that um innovation for
the future
is it is not just about tangible
uh property but it's all about
intangible property where you have
ar vr you know a design can be applied
to not just a physical product but also
a
non-physical product and this includes
graphic user interfaces as well
the recent changes in the law has as you
know
accepted guis and how they may apply
to an article for example on a mobile
phone such as an app
or even something that is non-physical
um
for example you could have a design of a
virtual keyboard
you know that is either in space or
projected on the table
so as you can see it's the the
the changes in the law um really reflect
how you know um the the government
and you know both internationally and in
singapore is trying to use
um designs as a
you know a key framework to boost uh
creativity
and innovation now some key takeaways
um you know having said all that earlier
um it's it's it it's very complicated
the the legal framework to
um the artistic work or design can be
very very complicated especially to
artists right
and you know it's very subjective as
well because
depending on what kind of work you do
you could be in the
architecture business you could be in
the graphic design business you could be
the gaming business
um all these rules and regulations apply
quite differently to you
um but you know the most important thing
to know is that
you know like like many types of ip
designs
drive value and they boost the value of
businesses
as well as the economy and you know as i
mentioned earlier
that ip is important
at in terms of the initial stage for you
to do an ip audit
of your own profile you need to know
that iep in general
is very important at every single stage
either
as an individual wanting to
expand your reach or whether as a small
company or even a large company
you know using ip to boost the growth
to delay the the future steps for
success
now um as an individual or perhaps as a
small company
you may be wondering okay you know what
steps do i take from here
what do you mean by an ip audit or you
know
perhaps whether or not i should register
something of mine or whether it's
it's not worth registering for example i
think i think
if we take a step back here um you need
to
perhaps when conducting your ip audit
you know you may want to seek the help
of organizations that are out there
that that you know that can they can
offer assistance to you
for example the intellectual property
office of singapore ipos
uh they do have their ways of of you
know
consulting with individuals or even
small firms to
help you understand what is your ip and
what you can do
for your ip and even organizations such
as design singapore themselves
or you know say licensed collecting
organizations
or you know you know artists represent
representation organizations
uh they they offer help readily as well
to to you know individuals especially if
you don't know what to do
and also if you need help for
professional assistance
or legal assistance you know there is an
abundance of
of law firms out there or even ip firms
or media firms out there you know that
could
provide some consultation as to you know
um
what you can do what you should do or
what you should not do
they are readily available and you can
just approach
someone out there for example
our firm ella chong we are one of the
the legal services
from the advice on intellectual property
and
um as you can see as a
firm that is you know ip boutique
laws law firm what we do is we advise
our clients at every stage of their pros
of their of their process or of their
you know
of their business so for example if
you're an individual
who you might not know what is your end
product or what's your angle
you could even do an ip audit at that
stage or for example you
are now at a stage where other people
are actually infringing on say your
design
at every at every stage you know from
start to end
we do we do advice on ip
for our clients and of course being a
full service law firm
we also advise on different legal
matters
uh from contentious and non-contentious
even to
commercial matters so for example if
you know it's if your if yourself or
your company has a
is is already established and you want
to you know
have consultation on franchising um we
do that as well
and of course you know we do have
services for corporate as well as
personal
uh legal services now thank you so much
uh for tuning in to my presentation
today
my i hope that you enjoyed today's
presentation and i hope that you have
found out
more about you know the intersection
between design
and what it is to be a registerable
design under the law in singapore
and as well as copyright um we we do
have a mailing list
that and we do you know generate a lot
of
material that is that is very
interesting as well so if you are very
interested in that
uh please feel free our qr code is up on
the screen now
um do register and you know as always if
you have any questions
um on the presentation
do feel free to drop me an email or give
up give me a call
um a lot of the information is is
condensed and it's very difficult to
you know explain over 30 minutes
of a presentation but if you have any
questions i i
i will be very happy to share more
and please feel free to reach out okay
i move over to felicia
all right thank you marcus for the
presentation and for sharing your
knowledge with us
as the design ecosystem continues to
evolve it is indeed important for
designers to remain aware of the various
ip laws that impact the way we create
so before we move further on into the
program i would like to take the chance
to introduce mr kevin wong
who will be joining us for the q a
segment so kevin is the director of ella
chung llc
and is an experienced attorney in the
field of ip management and transactional
work
and has advised a wide range of local
and foreign clients on their ip rights
and portfolios around the world
kevin is also a regular speaker at local
and international ip events
and is a consultant and tutor at local
ip clinics and courses
he has contributed articles and
commentaries to various ip publications
and also co-authored the singapore
chapter of the book
getting the due through trademarks so
thank you kevin for joining us
can invite you guys marcus and kevin
back on screen for the q a segment
hi yep so
we already have quite a few questions
streaming in from our audience
so maybe i can just start the ball
rolling with the first one
so okay somebody has asked us how long
can a design be registered for
and when does protection commence so
maybe we can get kevin to start first
and marcus if you have anything else to
add on you can
go after kevin yeah so
yeah everyone uh thanks for tuning into
this uh webinar a pleasure to be here
um on this question uh we're looking at
the jurisdiction of singapore then we
are looking at
a period of about a maximum period
of 15 years of protection that's the
question i'm trying to look for the
question right now on the screen
um yeah so that's the period of
protection
that uh you can uh enjoy
subject to uh you as the registrant
of the design applying to renew
your protection every five years from
the start of the term of protection
and the time protection actually starts
from
the date you filed your application
yeah so that's that's pretty much the um
so-called provisions that we have for
singapore design industrial designs
there could be some variations uh in
other countries
to when the definition starts for
the maximum duration of monopoly period
that you may enjoy
but in singapore it says 13 years all
right marcus anything else you'd like to
add or is that
maybe maybe i'd just like to add that
you know
if if you notice a design is normally
registered for as kevin said
five years and up to about 15 years
now you will note that this is slightly
different from other types of ip
for example a trademark is you know
normally 10 years
and and the reason behind this perhaps
is because you know the
design industry moves very quickly so
owners of designs may find that five
years later
your design may no longer be you know as
as profitable so this is why the the
production is shorter and they allow you
to
renew your protection in case you don't
want it after five years
all right all right so we have the next
question which is
how will i know if my design is new or
already registered elsewhere
markus or kevin would you like to take
this one
okay um yeah so i mentioned
earlier i i'm not sure if my slides are
still shared i don't think so but
um that there are databases where you
can actually search
for whether a design is registered
already in
singapore as well as overseas
these links are provided on the ipos
website
as well as vypos website so normally
when you go to
these databases they will actually show
you you know who who owns the
registration
and you could even see what article is
being applied
applied to and yeah these are readily
available public information
yeah yeah that's of course uh apart from
any of your own um
you know so-called your own research
which could be
done in in various ways you could try
doing some searching
uh nowadays google is pretty advanced uh
on searching things so there's even a
google images some type of search
[Music]
at least in singapore you might be able
to you might
you'll be looking around and seeing you
know what's what's out there in the
market right now
and um so that's that's on the
your own uh diy kind of uh surveying
level but then there are the other more
advanced ways of
doing searching and uh that's where
you could also get you know your option
of getting assistance from ip
practitioners who
um would know in for particular
jurisdictions
what sort of databases um would be
you know the most uh well
official or reliable to use and they
could also
help to provide opinions on um
you know the in terms of the
results that they get what are your
chances of you know uh
availability of your design a particular
country
based on what is already
registered or possibly also what is
really out there in the market
all right thank you kevin i think the
next question is probably something that
a lot of designers probably face
so somebody asked can you share some
tips on how designers and artists can
protect their work from
large organizations
so markets who should like to go first
okay that's a good question
i i imagine
an individual may be asking this if
you know for example you are you already
perhaps have a have a design for
something
and you are probably concerned as to
when you enter into a contract or into a
relationship with an organization you
know how to protect yourself
i imagine this is the context behind the
question
now as i shared a bit earlier
there are there are default positions on
who owns
your designs so it depends on whether or
not
you're an employee or whether the work
is being commissioned
it is important to either
you know check or to seek a seek
professional advice
as to what your your position what your
rights are
and before you know entering into any
contract with say a much larger
organization you need to know what are
the terms of the contract
whether or not there's any licensing
involved whether or not it's it's an
assignment or whether the work is being
commissioned
so track carefully before
before you you enter into a contract you
should probably
um find out the foundation of your work
and perhaps sig fi is very quiet
yeah um i think one one other thing i
would add
is uh well not just when you you know
you're
you know intending to you know uh
explore some sort of collaboration
uh with a large organization
organization but actually if anyone else
a third party whether big or not big or
not so big
um that well if you are into the stage
of
very um infant stage type
of uh discussions or about your
collaboration
uh so before things get into maybe a
more contractual stage
where there's uh decisions are made on
um
who is to uh house how things are gonna
be developed for um you know whatever
uh ip whatever
subject matter which has ip and body in
it
for example industrial designs uh design
rights
um would be to actually think of having
what we call non-disclosure agreements
if there's really some uh substantial
input that you might be uh considering
to well exposed
to a um you know before
going into a more substantial uh
kind of uh agreement or relationship
then uh with a non-disclosure agreement
then you are
well restricting the other side the
other party from
uh potentially making use of uh your
disclosures uh one to their own use
later
after uh you know the talks don't bear
fruit
eventually and it also
has another benefit of well in
a form of protection for um whatever
ip or potential ip rights
that you know were vested in whatever
was disclosed to that the party you
yourself actually decide
to uh apply for protection for
um you know the design right for example
um
yourself and let's say again um
the talks if the other organization
follows through
um because then you are protecting
yourself uh having
having pro uh you know had a
non-disclosure agreement
to protect yourself from the
issues that pertain to the requirements
for
obtaining protection which include the
novelty requirement
so you know your your design must be new
at the time that you file
the fact that you have you know put in a
non-disclosure evening will protect you
on that point on the novelty issue
or a novelty requirement thank you kevin
for the very detailed explanation
i think that kind of blends into our
next question as well so someone asked
how does the law differentiate between
inspired or copy content so where is
this line drawn
you know sometimes designers take a lot
of inspirations from other works you've
seen online
and things like that so how does the law
view um the boundaries between the
two of these areas yeah kevin would you
like to go first
um yeah this is uh interesting question
um i i would i would say i i don't think
that's there's really uh
any real ideal answer to this um because
um the answer would
almost always not always uh depend on
um looking at an actual factual
situation
that you may have in front of you uh
and um because whatev however
a design is conceptualized
ultimately if let's say it goes into a
dispute
where let's say the court has to decide
uh
if you know there was uh infringement
of uh you know another party's design
that that really is uh analysis that
uh would also depend on the
provisions of the country concerned
where the infringement took place in
certain countries
for example in singapore i would say
the finding or a finding of
infringement would more often than not
uh well be given in a case where
we have a very very close to copying
or copying you know very closely with uh
resembling
uh so-called uh reproductions
or what could say to be reductions of um
you know the
uh a plaintiff's uh design um
in certain other jurisdictions i would
say
from experience the european union for
example
the the rights that you obtain from a
design administration may actually
have more bites
in a sense because it may
take a bit less a bit less to uh
to for a finding of infringement
to be you know granted so
meaning that the degree of uh
similarity may be a bit less
than uh let's say you were
you know looking at this issue on
invention in the singapore
legal context so it all depends on
um really
the degree of uh similarity or
resemblance between
um you know the right sprite owners
design
and the third parties uh alleged uh
cockpit
uh design or yeah a design that copies
the
uh the other party's design
and so uh where you talk about
inspiration and all that yeah i believe
there are
um designs that well are based on
inspiration um but i am the day it is
to what extent that inspiration has led
to
um the third party's product
uh looking so similar to
the right schoolness design that you
know it's
taken as uh an infringement
and um like i said there's no real um
uh i you know a perfect answer to that
question
on where the line can be drawn
it really depends on what you're looking
at in a particular case
all right so maybe marcus you can take
the next one so
uh we have a question asking can i apply
for
trademark for my design
yeah um i think i'll start on this as
well because
this is a this is an interesting
question i would say
um it is actually rather uh
loaded loadout involved if you look at
the
various legal visions that might be in
place if you talk about the singapore
context
and looking at you know the provisions
of the designs act the basic design
exactly and the
trademarks act um i would say
um i i would not uh
say there's a any absolute bar to um
or you know absolute allowance of
trademarks
for designs being available or not
available
but i think one thing that should be
noted is that
we have uh some provisions in the
trademarks and
that may uh possibly
be raised as objections to um
registration of purely a design um as a
trademark uh
yeah and um i think uh
even more so if it's a registered design
um
how would this actually will uh pan out
in a real life situation um i
i can't really give a uh so-called 100
sure kind of answer to it it really
depends on how
the examiner is looks at things
how much research they might do um
if they look at the design uh at face
value without looking anything else
um some things may ultimately just come
to their mind
does this uh design uh
uh exclusively uh give substantial value
um to uh the products that they
represent
the product with the products themselves
so um
there is a provision which
you know can be can be used to
well prevent registration where
um the the trademark is seen as
just giving a substantial value um
and and designs are actually
uh you know potentially um you know such
uh subject matter that actually give
substantial value the value is in the
aesthetic value
that they display or they possess
and so there are potential bars to make
administration of
designs and trademarks but i wouldn't
say that
you know they will uh that there's there
is absolute prohibition so it really
depends again on
um the nature of the uh design that you
wish to
protect as a trademark
all right thank you kevin so we only
have time now for
one last question so perhaps you can
wrap things up with um
this one so this will be for the both of
you uh
based on your experience do you feel
like the new younger generation of
designers have enough awareness of ip
laws or is there a sensing that they do
not find it as important or relevant
so maybe we can get marcus to share our
thoughts and then maybe kevin you can
wrap things up for us
okay thanks that's a very interesting
question
um i think you know
um to see how the the youths
nowadays uh treat three design
or even other ip laws to that effect
you got to look at how the singapore
government
has has invested in
design as a tool for innovation
you know it's no longer
a a hobby for some people you know
designs or other types of ip
is emphasized as being important to the
economy
and you know you you see that the the
institutions that are set up in the past
10 to 30 years
the emphasis of ip and in particular
design
amongst the youth in schools nowadays i
would say
yes the youth nowadays they do
they do see design not just as a
simple hobby i mean it is a hobby yes
but it is
something that you know is a key driver
of success
and um i do believe that
compared to my time um
greater emphasis is placed on ip and we
do see schools
and you know organizations they do have
talks on the increased importance and
the awareness of ip nowadays
i can't speak for every single type of
ip perhaps there's
more work to be done on areas such as
copyright
infringement you know but in terms of
design
i do see the the emphasis by use in
singapore today
over to kevin yeah um
i i would like to think uh
marcus being um well in that so-called
at least like a younger generation uh
as compared to uh yours truly um
he's probably uh got the
perspective uh probably you know more
spot on i mean
or spot on so i i would i would say
um from my own observations that
because of i think our
current circumstances
how we have modernized and come to this
this stage of technological advancement
and
increase exposure and publicity uh
on you know the importance of ip
v8 designs or other forms of
intellectual property i i see actually
the younger generation
um uh having you know all the
um well the the kind of um
environment um to that is
really a lot more conducive than um what
was
available to uh well older folks like
myself
when i was growing up so i actually
really see
the awareness of ip laws uh
being something that should not really
be
um a huge challenge um
for uh you know our current uh
generation
of you know up and coming uh designers
and um i think with all the
information is available out there and
you know just over the internet or
in at the libraries and
with the you know increasing number of
webinars or
uh other forums where uh
people are talking about ip and of
course ip uh there are various platforms
where
the member generation actually you know
uh
get themselves uh a bit more immersed in
you know
developing that the support ip culture
of uh that would help them
as they develop as designers and
as they develop businesses for you know
developing their potential
as designers whether as their own
companies or if they
you know decide to uh join large
organizations and become designers
and employees of those design powered
companies
yeah all right thank you so much kevin
and marcus
so we're going to be wrapping up our q a
segment now uh just want to say thank
you to our attendees for participating
tas far and not to worry if we didn't
manage to answer all of your questions
we will be
addressing them via an email that will
be sent to you after the event
so thank you marcus and kevin for
sharing your advice and it's been a
pleasure having you join us today
right so moving on no worries
now i would like to hand over the time
to my colleague gaia
who will be sharing more on the design
singapore council's panel of shed
services for design firms
so gaia over to you please
thanks felicia uh thank you all for
taking time to join us today
i'm not sure how many of you have
actually heard about the dsg stretch
service
panel so i'd like to take this
opportunity to share more on this
initiative
first i'll be sharing on why design
firms can consider using
shared services second on the types of
services being offered in dsg panel of
services
and lastly how you can embark on this
journey if you're keen
so the council actually recognizes how
challenging it can be
for design firms to produce creative
work and also run the business at the
same time
so to help you support your day-to-day
operations
the council has actually worked with
several service providers
to offer preferential rates of 20 to 50
lower than the usual market rates thus
we hope that this will help you to
reduce
operating costs for design firms like
yours
by outsourcing the corporate functions
of your firm you could have
more time to focus on your creative work
and also your clients
you can actually rely on the service
providers to support you on the
administrative work
and ensure that the compliance or
statutory requirements are met
such as filing the yearly returns you
need not worried about best practices
for corporate functions as the service
providers will be there to guide and
support you
one of the key elements of outsourcing
is that you will learn the foundations
of business fundamentals
and understand how is it being done by
the service providers
this will strengthen your business
competencies and help you focus on
building
and taking your business to the next
level
currently our chat service panel offers
accounting corporate secretariat
services digital marketing
human resource ip management and public
relations services
will continue to include more categories
of services
in the future to better support you and
design firms in singapore
for the benefit of the larger design
community we
you can always recommend trusted service
providers that you work with
to join the panel we'll follow with
these service pro
service providers and do our best to
better to seek better rates out there
for design communities
now that you know the advantages of
shared services and what the panel of
service providers is offering
we encourage you to consider using
shared services
but before you embark on this journey
it's important for you to understand
and determine your firm's needs in terms
of
budget and the types of services that
you need
secondly we encourage you to talk to a
couple of service providers from the
same category openly
to discuss your needs and your budget
thereafter the service providers will
actually advise
and recommend the types of services with
the quotation
take this opportunity to assess the
suitability of the service providers for
you
lastly if you are agreeable with the
recommended services
and price packages and is satisfied with
the credential of the service provider
you may then proceed with the
appointment i hope this brief overview
gives you a rough idea of what shared
service initiative is all about
we welcome your feedback too for more
information on the shared service
initiative
please scan the qr code on the bottom
right or the bottom right
i'll now pass the time back to felicia
thank you
all right so thank you gaia for that
sharing so as mentioned uh more
information
on our shared services you can also find
the link in our zoom chat for easier
access
so now as mentioned at the beginning of
this webinar we're very happy to share
that
ella chong llc will be offering a
complimentary one-to-one preliminary
consultation for our attendees today
so if you'd like to sign up for one of
these sessions please scan the qr code
on the left side of your screen
we'd also appreciate it if you could
complete a simple survey for this
webinar at the same time to help us
improve on our future programs
a link to this form will also be shared
via the zoom chat right about now
and if you'd like to find out more about
the various upcoming programs that the
national design center has lined up
do scan the qr code that you see on the
right
so with that we'll be ending the session
for today thank you once again to all
speakers
marcus kevin as well as gaia and to all
of you for spending your thursday
afternoon with us
and we most definitely hope to see you
at our future events
have a great rest of the day and goodbye
you